hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Q&A about future of Science
and Technology I'm uh next week I will
finally be back in my natural habitat
and uh uh hopefully no technical things
will go wrong then they might today all
right let's see we have a whole bunch of
questions here
uh let's see
Elum enum asks do you think the plateau
of llms will be at the level of
understanding language once it does it
will start to taper off and we'll need
to use a different
technique um well let's see I think I
think I may have talked about this a
little bit before but there's sort of
the question
of we now have these n Nets with you
know billions hundreds of billions of
parameters and so on and we've bashed
them
to sort of get them to learn things that
for example consist of the text we put
on the web and so on the surprising
thing is that neuron Nets seem to be
able to learn all kinds of things and
seem to be able to extrapolate from the
things that they are fed in ways that
are similar to the ways that we humans
extrapolate things so kind of it's like
his here's a few billion pages of text
from the web here's a piece of a
sentence continue the sentence the way
that you would expect it would be
continued based on what you've seen on
the web and the neuronet will
successfully make that continuation now
there are all these questions about the
big surprise I suppose with with chat
gbt for example is that not only could
you go a few words ahead you could write
a whole essay and have the things stay
fairly coherent and as time's G gone on
the sort of the context window for the
llm as it writes the next word how far
back can it look that context window has
gotten bigger the ability to sort of
remain coherent over a longer period
it's gotten better there still isn't yet
kind of true planning of what's going to
happen next it's still writing a word at
a time looking at the past one can
certainly imagine there sort of ideas
one might even call them kind of quantum
llms where you're kind of looking at all
the paths that could follow in the
future and sort of preemptively picking
between those paths to be able to do
more kind of planning of what the llm
where the llm is going rather than just
saying I will continue from what I had
so far um and there's a lot that we've
been deeply involved in and we'll be
even more involved in uh of having the
llm call computational tools and actual
computational knowledge whether W from
alpha W from language whatever um being
able to sort of get that feedback of
some sort of hard computation rather
than just oh it roughly looks right
based on the statistics of what the
neural net learned I think there's sort
of a a question of of to what
extent is it is it going to be you just
take these neural Nets you make them
bigger stronger you you feed them more
more material they'll sort of get
progressively better my guess is and
this has happened multiple times before
in the history of machine learning I
know I've talked about this uh at other
times that there are these thresholds
that get reached it's kind of like 20 12
sort of recognition of objects 5,000
kinds of objects okay that got solved
with kind of the deep learning idea um
other kinds of ideas about um speech to
text and so on got solved image
generation you know stable diffusion
kinds of ideas and so on got sort of
solved the basic question of how do you
do uh kind of AI generated images now in
each of these cases there's sort of a a
basic threshold you get past and things
sort of start to work and they're
they're useful then there's a question
can you tighten it up it gets more and
more difficult to tighten it up and
often these kinds of techniques with
machine learning are quite hard to
tighten
up sort of traditional software
engineering programming kinds of things
are often easier to tighten up it's kind
of like add this special case here add
that special case there that's not
something that one gets to do with
machine learning it's a much more
holistic thing you can train it this way
you can give it some reinforcement
learning here it's much more difficult
to say I want to make this specific
change and have this specific thing
happen and I think what we've certainly
seen is this sort of a threshold is
reached and the threshold is passed we
get to some amount of functionality then
it's sort of gradual improvement over a
long period of time uh without with you
know a certain amount of of tweaking but
it isn't as systematic as it might be
you kind of have what you have based on
that sort of level of machine learning
now the question is what are the next
thresholds I'm I'm sure that
understanding videos is going to be an
important thing something that's already
started but being able to say I know
what happens in the world because I've
seen all these billions of hours of
video of things that happen in the world
whether they're things that happen
mechanically in the world whether
they're things that happen with people
and so on those are things where one can
expect that that will be a thing that
will routinely be sort of aable in in
the future I think there are different
questions about sort of what one gets to
when one can understand language in in
certain kinds of ways I mean uh the very
idea of language language is a sort of
way of packaging thoughts in a way that
is communicable to another mind sort to
speak and the sort of the really big
idea of language is this sort of
compositionality idea the idea that
rather than just saying uh it's a rock
it's a chair you know little nouns like
that you can put together a whole
sentence where where there sort of a
construction kit of different pieces of
the sentence and you can say a red chair
was next to a blue table and you don't
have to have kind of a a separate word
for blue table and and a separate word
for that whole concept you can compose
together these different pieces and make
a piece of meaning by composing those
pieces together that's sort of the the
key idea of language so to speak and
it's sort of anchored with the with the
core words that define Concepts in
English we have 40,000 of them or
something commonly used um and uh but
they get to be combined in all these
different ways to make all the things we
might say in the language and so that
idea of sort of packaging ideas
packaging Thoughts by this sort of
composable elements anchored to Concepts
represented by words that's the core
idea of language and so there's a
question you know as you put the AIS in
place and and they start to look at the
world and they start to be able to make
inferences about what will happen in the
world based on watching videos and
things like that will there be some
different form of summarization of the
world that the AIS can come up with it's
different from language as we have it
for example for for us humans you can
imagine there are sort of pictorial
languages there's sort of iconography
there's there's user interfaces there's
things like this those over the last
particularly I would say over the last
few decades have come to be sort of
another level of kind of a a
communication with humans there's
certain things you expect in a user
interface there's certain kinds of
things that a user interface can
communicate or that infographics can
communicate and it's a little different
and you know there's often the statement
you know a picture is worth a thousand
words so to speak there's somewhat
different things you can communicate in
pictures than with words although they
don't have quite the same kind of
compositionality that language seems to
have
apparently and so you know that's a case
where we're starting to sort of poke at
a different form of communication not
quite as systematic as the one that
we've developed with language but it
gives kind of a sense of of where one
might see sort of other forms of
communicating ideas now you know will
the AIS
between themselves for example come up
with a way of packaging ideas thoughts
that is very different from what we
humans have come up with possibly um I
think that it is and then will the thing
that they come up with be something that
we humans can learn my guess is if the
AI come up within the AI of neural Nets
we humans will be able to learn it but
there will be challenges for example it
could be that with a sufficiently big
neuronet you'll be able to have a
language with a million words in it
whereas you know compared to the 40,000
we might have in in our languages today
it does seem to be the case that there's
some kind of scaling between the sort of
the size of the brain the number of
neurons the number of artificial neurons
in the artificial brain actual neurons
in the in the sort of physical brain the
number of kind of neurons in the brain
and the number of distinct words that
you can be dealing with like you know we
have 100 billion neurons give or take we
can deal with 40 ,000 words uh you know
this is the question of sort of the the
I don't know how many how many words can
an ant deal with it has 50,000 neurons
it's some much smaller number it seems
of sort of Concepts that an ant can
perhaps communicate um and so then the
question comes if we start to have
neuron Nets that have you know tens of
trillions of neurons in them then is
there can that deal with a larger
collection of Concepts what does it mean
to deal with these Concepts what it
basically means means is as we take what
we see from the world and we say this
whole collection of different images
they all correspond to the same concept
how many different sort of attractors of
different kinds of forms of input that
lead to the same concept can we fit in
the space of our brains so to speak or
is it the case if our brain has a
certain number of neurons and we start
saying we want to pack more and more and
more Concepts necessarily they'll get
confused because the the sort of the the
the attractor the the pattern of brain
activity that we recognize as the
concept of a cat the pattern of brain
concept of a dog if you try and pack too
many cats and dogs or different kinds of
Concepts in there there'll be start to
be overlap and you'll start to not be
able to distinguish these things and
that's probably a thing that is
distinctly associated with sort of
number of neurons and brains and so you
know what will it be like for example if
we could have an AI that knows a million
words that has identified a million
Concepts about the world and that is
able to distinguish those million
Concepts it's kind of a little little
bit like when we look at a specialized
area of language I don't know medical
jargon or something like this there are
a bunch of different words that the
typical person won't immediately know
but which are useful for communicating
medical Concepts and which somehow uh
leverage they somehow go further with
language than we could go with the
everyday words and when we have the
million word AI or something it's
probably going to be able to make a
bunch of distinctions that we don't in
our everyday language make and what it
will sort of feel like to deal with such
an AI is an interesting question I don't
completely know I've sort of been
wondering a little bit about it um I
think but but anyway that that would be
my thought about uh uh sort of what the
next level of quotes understanding
language now is there a form of
organization of ways to package thoughts
that is fundamentally different from
language perhaps more efficient than
language perhaps that's achievable by a
thing that can keep more Concepts in
mind or some such other thing I don't
know I mean I think that before language
existed I think it would have been quite
hard I mean very hard to project to this
kind of other mind situation very hard
to imagine what it would be like if one
had language if one didn't have language
now I suppose an example where we get to
see a example of this is our
computational language you know W
language which is something that sort of
didn't exist and now it does exist and
we can kind of start to see how that
clarifies one's thinking about certain
kinds of things and to to sort of have
that in its full form and to I mean
since I've sort of lived the from before
that existed to when that existed so to
speak it's been interesting to see the
extent to which sort of the existence of
computational language helps one think
thoughts in a different way and helps
one kind of compose thoughts in a
different way so I suppose maybe that's
an example which perhaps one should
think about more carefully of sort of
what it might feel like to deal with the
AI that let's say knows a million words
has a different level of sort of
language likee thing maybe we already
have an example of that in the
computational language that that we
built so anyway a few thoughts about
that all right let's see lots of other
questions here um
well let's see uh okay few few
responding to this point and then we'll
come to some others
um uh Kant says how do you know our
brains aren't already using compression
our brains do use a lot of compression
that's kind of how we go from all the
complexity of the world to just using
words to describe what's going on it
that is really a story of compression
that's really a story of taking every
little pixel Arrangement that might
correspond to the camera I'm seeing in
front of me and just saying it's a
camera that's that's a sort of an act of
compression and it is a key thing that I
think kind of beings that can observe
entities that can observe the world make
use of it's a it's a key feature of
being a mind that you go from the
complexity of the world all the atoms
bouncing around as they bounce around to
something where you've concentrated that
into a thing that corresponds to a sort
of coherent stream of
thought
um let's
see uh LLY comments the AI could make
far more precise classifications than we
leading to new words and with very
precise meaning the thing to understand
about words and the Precision of meaning
and so on
is the whole point is this idea of
compression I'm just saying it's a
camera in front of me I could say it's a
camera that's this shape with this thing
and that thing and that thing and I'll
call that a um you know a camera log
camera logo blah blah blah some
complicated word um and that means a
camera with those characteristics and I
have some other camera blah that has a
camera with some other characteristics
and pretty soon if I have a different
word for everything I see I can no
longer abstract things I mean one of the
key ideas of Minds is the abstraction
from the details of the world to things
that there is a narrative about that
Minds can reason in terms of so you know
it's sort of a be careful what you wish
for in terms of of having more words for
things because if you sort of have too
many words you don't get to make any
generalizations you don't get to
abstract anything it's it's a question
of can you have the words different
words for things that you care about
making distinctions about and not
different words for things that should
be complated
together
let's
see
um an yes comments seems more important
is the speed of the medium that AI has
and how quickly it can process all the
interrelations however many um uh
however many Concepts there are yeah I
think that's interesting and I think you
know you got to recognize that human
brains you know our neurons fire you
know every few milliseconds or something
in um uh in computers things are
happening every
nanc it's you know the fundamental
Hardware of computers is a million times
faster than the fundamental Hardware of
our brains right now we still have the
advantage that all our neurons are sort
of active all the time and are able to
learn all the time we don't quite yet
have that in machine learning systems
but I'm sure we will and then we will
have the situation where the fundamental
Hardware is a million times faster and
there is a very interesting questions
about what the world would look like if
you could perceive it a million times
faster I mean I realized that for
example you know light doesn't you
you'll perceive the speed of light if
you think a million times faster you'll
notice that the light is coming from
there bouncing off the the other wall in
the room and doing this and that and the
other a bit like how you hear Echoes and
sound and things like this you'll you'll
notice a lot of things that we don't
notice at the speed we can perceive
things it's also the case that sort of
in terms of sensory put you know we have
whatever 10 million nerve fibers in our
optic nerves going from our eyes to our
brains but one can imagine that one
could sort of detect from every internet
device you know every iot device in the
world you know let's say it's a billion
devices you could if you had a faster
bigger brain you could be getting input
from all of those devices all the time
and then forming in a sense a perception
of reality from a a vastly richer kind
of sensory experience I don't know what
the sensory experience of a billion iot
devices will be like we in our brains
you know we've got our visual cortex
organized to make use of the spatial
relationships between pixels you know we
know what it means for these these these
nerves in our retina to be the photo
receptors in our retina to excite nerves
and two neighboring nerves so to speak
we know that they are geometrically
nearby
and that's important to our our vision
of the concept of forming an image so to
speak what does that look like for a
billion iot devices distributed perhaps
geographically perhaps functionally
whatever else that there will be some
sort of collective view of the world
just like we have this view of images as
being this two-dimensional thing that
will be formed from that sort of
collection of the iot experience of the
world and I'm not sure what that will be
I think that we can say the same thing
for all kinds of of detailed sensory
inputs whether we have let's say chem
here's an example we do have some
experience of let's say we have chemical
sensors which detect roughly the shapes
of molecules by having you know let's
say A protein that the molecule of
different lots of different shapes and
the molecule is binding to those
different shapes little bit like how the
immune system recognizes things but
let's imagine we just have this array
and we certainly have technology that
that does this we have an array where we
have a bunch of proteins that are sort
of attached to some array and it's like
a molecule comes in and which protein it
binds to determines what nerve impulse
is produced well what is that well
that's like smell and taste that's kind
of how those work and now the question
is what is our map of smell space taste
space whatever well we humans at least
most of us don't have a great version of
that map if you say how are things laid
out in physical space yeah we understand
that if you say how are things laid out
in Al Factory space I I don't think most
of us would have a good thing to say
about that I don't know dogs might have
a perception of that because they pay
much more attention to ALF faction but I
think that that's a that's an example of
sort of trying to see what trying to
imagine what we could get to if we had
sort of you know let's imagine we could
detect the shapes of all the molecules
and and and let's imagine that with
faster thinking we could do that across
more molecules what would we then
conclude about the world how would we
then summarize the world because I think
the point is that that one of the things
to realize is yes things happen in the
world that involve lots of computation
but the things that connect to our minds
that we pay attention to are things that
are somehow matched to the way that our
minds work which means you have to
reduce it to this sort of stream of
Concepts that our minds can process
otherwise you're kind of you're dealing
with the AIS I'm kind of thinking the
AIS on Mount Olympus or something that
the AI gods are doing all that things
and every so often something sort of
falls down to the level of Mortals so to
speak and we get to understand it and
most of the time it's just sort of AIS
doing their thing with AIS and and how
would we describe that we probably
describe that much like we try and
describe Natural Science much like we
describe the natural world we say well
there's all these things going on and
all these detailed patterns of behavior
etc etc etc but the thing we really care
about is that a tornado formed for
example the details of every little
Eddie that made the tornado we don't
really care about that we just care
about the big story of a tornado formed
and I suspect it's the same kind of
thing in the case of the of the AI
there Lynn asked the question which
language is best at this compression I
suppose the the um the compression of
ideas into into
thoughts it's a good question I mean
there certainly when you look at
different languages and you say let's
take this book Let's translate it from
English into French you know it's a bit
longer in French just the number of
letters in all the words is a bit longer
in French um and one knows you know Mor
malfa for example I know we have
translation lengths that we computed at
some point typical translation lengths
for how long will a book be it's
relevant if you're if you're translating
a big book like my new kind of science
book it's kind of like how how much does
it puff out when you translate it into
some language other than English English
is one of the most compact of the
languages alphabetically written
languages um and I think
this question of of well what uh what
language best compresses there there are
artificial languages constructed
languages that have many fewer words
than English down to you know 150 words
or something um but the issue with those
languages is it's hard to express
elaborate philosophical ideas in those
languages those languages might be good
for sort of the everyday I want to get a
cup of coffee type thing but they're not
going to be good for sort of the
detailed philosophical discourse just as
in talking about some specialized area
whether it's medicine or Finance or
whatever it is knowing the jargon of
that area is useful for communication in
that area
so I think um uh with respect to sort of
how you express things in language and
what sort of takes the concepts we care
about and expresses them as succinct as
possible interesting question big
project that we're working on right now
is this thing that I call symbolic
discourse language which is an attempt
to make a computational version of of a
way of expressing kind of everyday
discourse my guess is that that will be
a very succinct version that takes the
essence of sort of Concepts that are
being communicated in language and
really boils them down to the sort of
computational essence of course when you
do that that you you lose a certain
Nuance you you lose the it's just like
when people go to wol malfa and they say
please can you compute the following uh
differential equation or something like
this it doesn't care that you said
please can you do this it just says
there's a differential equation here I'm
going to do my thing if you said very
poetically you know uh work out
something about some genomics thing that
that wol malfa can compute and you say
imagine you know there is a you know the
the boat is crossing the genomic sea and
it's got this and this and this well if
W can figure out what's going on it's
just going to say you want me to go
compute this thing about what happens
Upstream of this Gene and it'll go and
compute that it's crushed The Poetry out
of it and in a sense it's it's often the
case that in the end you know when you
hear language and you would hear it's
like what's the difference between
people who communicate by email people
who commun Comm unicate in person it's
like sometimes in my world of of running
companies and so on it's sometimes when
you tell people that you know you'll
have people and they'll be sort of
feuding with each other by email and
they'll be sending these kind of kind of
growly emails back and forth at each
other and it's like just pick up the
phone and talk to each other because
what you get from that additional level
of communication of hearing the the the
the tenor of the voice so to speak as
well as sort of just seeing the words
you get a different amount of
communication which hopefully can help
resolve
things
uh let's see there's a question here
from Lis is there room for significant
advancements in mathematical
notation well I like to think that our
computational language is that story
that notation I mean we've done a lot
over the years to kind of take what is
the traditional mathematical notation
and just clean it up a bit so it's
really consistent and and able to be
systematically understood I mean
otherwise you end up in these crazy
situations where yes you write it down
that way but it's really hard to
understand I mean I in the history of
mathematical notation there are famous
examples like the time sign invented by
a chap called William outred um liit who
was really intern notational kinds of
things said people will confuse that
with an X you should use a different
symbol but it didn't catch on like liet
himself with his d by DX notation for
calculus worried that people would think
you could cancel the D's which is
obviously things that a thing that
happens in kind of calculus classes for
the last 300 and something years so sort
of a bad notation we've tried to in in
wol from language and a Mathematica
we've tried to sort of clean up these
notations a bit so they're still
recognizable as being those notations
but nevertheless made precise and uh
that's uh and so I think that you only
get a certain amount of of of stuff that
you can expect somebody to to learn
notationally one of the mistakes made in
a language called APL a very interesting
language built by a person called caners
in the 1960s kind of an array processing
language um the APL stood for a
programming language but um uh it was
early days but any case it was a sort of
attempt to make a notation for
computation but it really didn't work
out well it had all kinds of weird
symbols there were special APL keyboards
all this kind of thing people didn't
learn 30 or 40 new symbols that was too
much but what we managed to do in wol
language was we leverage English we use
English words and people have an idea
what the thing means just by reading the
English words and it makes it much
easier to memorize much easier to stuff
it in a brain to have that that familiar
language there and I think that's sort
of the future of of kind of in a sense
mathematical notation is computational
notation and that's what I've spent much
of my life trying to build is a
consistent sort of computational
notation for expressing things about the
world leveraging in most cases kind of
English as names of functions and always
having that as as the back stop even if
there might be some you know slash at
notation that's the thing that the
experts get to use it's still map or you
know let's say map apply triple at sign
um is you know the experts can use
triple out sign but in the end it's map
apply and you can kind of know what that
means let's
see
uh let
see so many questions here brich says a
single uh
biological neuron can perform an
exclusive ore operation a current single
artificial neuron can't do that do we
think we're underestimating the power of
biological neurons compared to
artificial
neurons see this is an interesting
question when you are doing Neuroscience
you're modeling
brains there are lots of details in in
the neurons that we have in our brains
what matters what
doesn't it's like in physics you could
say I'm studying mechanics
I'm throwing an object off the Tower of
Pisa or something and I want to know
does it matter that it had spikes on the
edges or does the only thing that
matters to how fast it will fall is it
just the
mass well there are details because
there's air resistance in that case
there wouldn't be if it was in a vacuum
and so on it's like what matters what
doesn't and it of course depends a bit
on what you are asking for what output
you're asking for if it's a question of
if we generate language if we do our
thinking kinds of things to generate
language what matters what doesn't do
the twitching of the dendritic spines on
the individual neurons in our brains
does that matter to the production of
language or not or is that
irrelevant I think the thing we've
leared from sort of the chat GPT
Discovery invention um is that less
matters about the details of artificial
biological neurons than we might have
thought because we can get a pretty good
result for generating language from
these pure artificial neural neural Nets
now there are clearly things about
biological neural Nets that are
different like for example you put in
you know you have you bathe your neurons
in your brain with some uh uh
neurotransmitter some hormone something
like that you bathe it in some overall
Global chemical so to speak you change
the mood of your neural net um you know
you uh uh you have some drug and you
change the overall behavior of the
neural net what's the analog of that an
artificial neural net actually I've done
some experiments on that of of an
artificial neural Nets of of making sort
of overall changes in the weights and
the neural Nets seeing what happens
seeing how you can kind of blow the mind
of the artificial neural that kind of
interesting to see what happens there
it's it's kind of very much like the the
picture that you have of sort of blowing
a a human mind so to speak but it it's
um so I I don't think you know they
differences between artificial neural
Nets biological neural Nets but what
matters and for what purpose and I think
this question of for example what's the
memory capacity of human brains is the
memory stored in a few bits per syapse a
few bits per connection between between
nerve cells or is it stored in all sorts
of detailed molecular information that
is more at a molecular scale than at the
scale of individual neural individual
ual nerve cells I think the suspicion is
that it really is at the level of
individual of nerve cells which is what
people have suspected since at least the
1930s or
1940s and not at some much more detailed
molecular level but might be wrong but
but that seems to be what we're
discovering from looking at the
capabilities of artificial neural Nets
when it comes to the way neural Nets
work I mean it it's remarkable how very
straightforward it is and how very
similar it is to the way that the very
first artificial neuron Nets from 1943
were described it's kind of like you're
just adding up a bunch of a bunch of
inputs with certain weights and you're
thresholding that in some way with some
activation function that's it and yes
there are lots of things that it's kind
of hard it's easy to prove theorems that
say that if you have a hidden layer
between the input and the output if it's
a big enough layer you can in principle
compute anything but in practice what
can you learn learn by training what you
know how how easy is it to compute
particular functions good question I've
studied this a little bit what functions
are easy to compute what functions are
hard to compute um that is something
probably gives us information about um
if if we if we followed that path well
enough it would give us information
about things we humans find easy things
we humans don't find easy assuming that
this model of artificial neuronet is an
accurate model and I think it's a
reasonable question what what functions
what things are easy to to compute with
neural Nets what are not I mean the
thing to understand is digital computers
are very much based on kind of ones and
zeros on and off everything is
discret neural Nets are in their
current sort of construction are
fundamentally continuous one's dealing
with just oh one feeds in this number
you know even if you're feeding in words
you're turning them into numbers and
then the weights are precise numbers
1735 or whatever else it is and if you
if you bash the thing to be trained to
learn something slightly different that
1735 might turn into
1737 and that little extra you know
change might at some moment as you go
through the noret that right might
really matter because you might just go
above some threshold for some activation
function or not depending on that
precise value but so neural Nets are
kind of a continuous model of
computation the way they're set up right
now my guess is that's quite unnecessary
that actually there's a way of of
Distributing the kind of just as neural
Nets neurons and neural Nets there are
many in parallel I think that those bits
that one's packing into numbers right
now probably can also be distributed and
sort of run in parallel so it's like
many bits make up the analog of one
number rather than everything having to
be in that sort of continuous number
it's very similar I probably use this
analogy a zillion times to what happens
in fluid mechanics where there's sort of
a continuous velocity of fluid but
that's really made up of lots of
underlying discrete molecules that that
exist in in a discrete form and I
suspect the same thing could be done for
neuronet so I don't think that's a a
fundamental feature but this this
question about sort of what matters in
biological neuron Nets what do we what
matters what do we have to emulate to
achieve certain functionality
interesting question I think the current
evidence seems to be on the side of the
things that people modeled in 1943 about
how neuron Nets might work are probably
good enough to capture the essence of
what's needed for thinking kinds of
processes
um memes asks did the neural Nets I was
playing with learn after their minds
were
blowing
um I would
think I'm not sure so what I did was you
take the weights in a neural net you've
trained the neural net to be able to
generate images and you say let's take
all those weights and let's just
increase the values just you know
multiply them by 1.01 1.02 etc etc etc
and for example what I was doing was
saying make a picture of a cat in a
party hat and do that where you the the
the neural net keeps on getting adjusted
well you know you do it for different
for differently sort of inflated neural
net weights and what you see is the cat
looks pretty good by remember numbers
you can look up in the writing that I
did about this um the you know let's say
at 1.01 it's still looking pretty
cat-like by
1.05 the cat is starting to sort of you
know have bizarre green things sticking
out of its head and so on and by you
know 1.07 the cats kind of exploded and
there isn't really a cat to be seen
anymore now could one given that sort of
exploded Network that that amped up
Network NW work could one go and take
that Network and continue training it my
guess is yes but that training in a
sense eventually that training will just
revert if you train it enough it's going
to revert to what it learned before if
it's the same training data but so if
it's a question of fine-tuning from that
Network how far can fine tuning go I
don't know the answer good question I
just don't
know
um gosh so many new questions coming in
here I I want to come back to some of
the the earlier ones here but but um
there's a question here from
Hassan what's your view of emergent
phenomena do you think it's possible to
predict all the emergent abilities that
AI can obtain well absolutely not I mean
one of the fundamental things I kind of
discovered in the 1980s is this
phenomenon that even very simple
programs can produce very complicated
Behavior the programs we tend to choose
to write with a particular purpose in
mind just do what the purpose we had in
mind was was assuming that they don't
have bugs we didn't expect but if you
just pick little tiny programs that just
say how to update you know AR raise of
bits or something like this if you just
pick those programs kind of at random
you just start enumerating from the
simplest programs on you you quickly
find out that you'll end up with
programs or you look at the program you
say this is a simple program you run it
oh my gosh it's doing all this
incredibly complicated stuff that I
never expected that is the generic
behavior that you see out in the
computational universe of possible
programs I think it is also the generic
Behavior you see in a lot of systems in
nature where nature isn't under the
constraint that one should be able to
understand what it does so it just runs
some program and it does what it does it
makes that complicated turbulent fluid
it makes that elaborate biological
pattern these kinds of things it's it's
just going out and sort of in the
computational universe producing things
lots of stuff emerges there's this
fundamental phenomenon that I call
computational irreducibility that
basically says when you have one of
these programs and it's running and it's
doing what it does there's the question
can you jump ahead and say I know what
it's going to do I know the final answer
well computational irreducibility says
you you generically can't do that you
have to follow the steps and just see
what it does which is another way of
saying there'll always be unexpected
things that will happen because if
everything was if you could always Jump
Ahead you would be able to expect
everything it would be it's the
unexpected is what happens through
computational irreducibility and yes
there are always unexpected things that
will happen even in systems with very
simple rules let alone the systems we
have with all these AIS and so on yes
unexpected things will happen and this
is a fundamental kind of societal thing
for the future is kind of if you want
computation and AIS to do the things
that computation and AI can do to have
the sort of power of computational
capability that's then you are signing
up for computational IR reducibility
you're signing up for the fact that the
things that can happen can include
things that you cannot foresee would
happen so in other words you say I'm
going to set the system up it's going to
do what it does and if you say I never
want it to do this I never want it to do
that that's very hard to achieve if you
say I just want the system to follow do
you know follow this track well yes you
can get it to follow the track but then
you can't have it have the true power of
computation true irreducible computation
you're then constraining it and yes you
can understand what it's going to do but
it won't be able to do those the
interesting things it won't be able to
do almost the creative things it will
only be able to do the things that it
was sort of reflexively programmed to
do let's
see
um and so so by the way that that is you
know that is the the sort of the future
of of computation and so on is is this
thing where you're not going to be able
to predict what will
happen in it is interesting in a sense
that just as you won't be able to
predict what happens in the physical
universe but I think in a sense we're
we're changing the rules more quickly in
AI than they get changed in physics and
so we're kind of seeing at an
accelerated rate this phenomenon of kind
of computational irreducibility is more
in our face in the case of AI than it
has been in the case of the natural
world
let's see Brady asked will humanoid
robots usher in an age of
abundance well you know the world as
we've built it is built for us humans
you know we have steps that go from here
to there which are about the right size
for human legs to walk up them we have
all kinds of things in our environment
that are built for humans you know we
have lights that um allow us to see in
the visual spect part of the El Spectrum
we have uh things that are predictable
to us we have rooms that are you know in
in rectangular shapes that we can sort
of predict we have the the world as we
have built it is built for us humans now
the natural world wasn't built for us
humans although biological evolution has
made us kind of adapt to those the
niches that are naturally available
there you know if we go start colonizing
Mars or something we're out of that game
we're we're we're out of what we were
ever evolved to be to be in so to speak
and uh so so then it's kind of a
different issue of of whether we are
whether whether we're sort of suitable
for the world as it is but so when we
have robots that we want to exist in the
world as we have built it out or as we
have evolved to
it if they're humanoid robots they're
going to fit in they're going to be able
to walk up the steps they're going to be
able to open the door they're going to
be able to do these things that were
built for humans now what will that
allow to have happen I think a lot of
things that were a lot of mechanical
things that were very human specific now
we can automate those things I mean you
know a lot of things about uh you know
we've been able to automate things about
you know the robot vacuum cleaner type
thing when the when the floor is pretty
simple and not too many too many weird
things happen there not too many steps
that can fall down all those kinds of
things like this we can we can automate
that when we have sort of more
completely humanoid kinds of of of uh of
of setups then we can expect that yes it
can it can have its own mop or something
that it carries like a human does and
the the the environment the house was
built so that it um uh was you know moop
by a human so to speak and it will then
be mo by a humanoid robot
know what will that there will be
certain kinds of things that can be
automated I mean there's there's an
awful lot over the course of time as
technology progresses there are things
that were kind of you know really hard
to do that became easy to do like you
know cars got there were things where
well you used to have to have you know
your horse and somebody would feed your
horse and you would do the you know all
the things with somebody would be the
person who would uh uh your you know
Uber driver for the uh for the carriage
or something like this except I don't
think they had the well I don't know if
they had the I think the gig economy was
different in those days but in any case
the the the thing that was um uh you
know you would have this whole
infrastructure for feeding the horses
doing this with that um or if you have
you know using airships you would have a
whole infrastructure for dealing with
it's going to take a long time to go
across the Atlantic or something there's
a whole different infrastru structure
and then the technology comes in and
then certain things become much simpler
much faster etc etc etc then we adapt to
that and then a whole another level of
of human activities emerges and I think
the same will be true of humanoid robots
there are things where you say you know
it we might have said in the past even
you know 150 years ago it's like
fundamentally you're going to have to
grow well maybe not maybe a little
longer ago than that fundamentally
you're going to have to grow your own
food most people in developed countries
these days do not grow their own food
unless they think that that's fund so to
speak um and you know there's an
infrastructure that built up where we
mostly don't grow our own food but yet
and similarly you know there's a at the
time you know there was a time when
mostly people would always wash their
own dishes but then there were
dishwashers that got you know that
automated that and you know there's a
there's this whole sort of train of what
gets automated the thing that is
interesting about as humans and it's
sort of a computational irreducibility
story applied to us humans is there's
always stuff to do that hasn't yet been
automated that and I think that will
always be the case there is always stuff
to do that hasn't been automated that
isn't sort of systematic enough that
it's yet been automated or automatable
now we could choose to say okay enough
is enough uh we can just uh you know
hang out and um uh sit back and the
machine peel the grapes and we'll just
eat them and we won't really do much
else and it'll will just hang out for
our lives kind of you know eating peeled
grapes and uh and and that's all we'll
do um if if we're in that um situation
if we decide we just don't care about
anything new and different well then yes
we will get to the point where the
things that we care about so far can be
automated and they're very easy to get
I think the thing that has been the case
and as I say I suspect will in a sense
it's an inevitable feature of
computational irreducibility is there's
always more to do and so there's always
more to do that is hard to do I mean I
know in uh you know I tend to be a
person who ends up trying to do things
where I manage to automate a whole bunch
of stuff manage to figure out learn
about a bunch of stuff then there's
always a frontier there's always more to
do there's always more to figure out and
there's always a thing that's hard to to
do next so to speak speak and and I
suppose it's just a choice of somebody
like me I'm always going to try and you
know try and do that thing that seems
hard to do and maybe as a as a species
as a society we could all just say
enough is enough we're done in which
case yes the humanoid robots can be our
kind of automated Butlers and so on and
and and sort of we can just hang out but
my guess is there'll always be hard
stuff for us to do and it's a question
of of and they'll and then there'll be
the stuff that's sort of the automated
away stuff that we just say oh yeah yeah
of course you know don't worry you just
go to the go to the grocery store and
buy the food you don't have to grow that
food and and and the same with lots of
other things I think there will be some
some thresholds with with as robotics
gets better oh for example Industries
like the construction industry which has
been not very automated and involves a
lot of people um and you know what
happens when robots can routinely do
construction well a lot of things that
were expensive before become much
cheaper like build a house take a house
down again you know maybe at the point
where there are things where you know
where where everything is built
robotically maybe it's like oh yeah you
put up this house oh yeah you want to
move your house okay we'll get robots to
disassemble the house again and
reassemble it somewhere else and that
will be cheap enough to do that it can
realistically be done just like there
were plenty of things that where the
things one does today um in the past one
wouldn't ever have imagined that one
could you know pick something up and
move it to another place even with
computers for example in my in my life
the first computer I used was weighed
probably a ton or so and it was you know
the size of a big desk it was and so on
even the the computers that I was using
back in Oh by the end of the 1970s early
1980s those were computers you couldn't
move and the concept that I can take a
fully capable computer and pick it up
move it around is a remarkable concept
when I remember I first had a laptop
computer and I first had a portable
computer the Osborne one computer I
think in 1981 was the size of a suitcase
and it certainly didn't run off
batteries and it was a sort of a funky
thing to to make use of and I didn't
make that much use of it actually and
then later there was a thing that was
really a laptop size it wasn't a very
powerful computer yet that that you
could really just put in a bag take with
you I I remember in at the point when
computers got to the point where I could
easily put a computer in an envelope
vope that was another thing where it
became much more portable and and it's
the same type of thing with with things
like let's say construction Like Houses
you know can you realistically build a
house take it down again build it again
somewhere else probably yes with with
you know when robotics gets to the point
where it's capable enough and and cheap
enough
um brich asks can a higher intelligence
ever trans computational
irreducibility well here's the here's
the thing within computational
irreducibility there are always pockets
of redu ability things that we can do
even though the to do everything we
can't but there are particular places
where we can have technology we can have
ideas that say yes we can figure out
that little piece this piece here this
piece there it's sort of inevitable that
we can we can put all these patches on
we'll never get the whole way we can put
any number of patches on the more
patches we put on sort of interesting
that if we put enough patches on the
thing that's doing the patching is
itself going to get very very bloated
it's kind of like by the time we've got
enough sort of uh sort of axioms of our
mathematical theory that that
everything's an axiom you know we just
let's say oh yeah we got a mathematical
Theory theorem you know the rean
hypothesis gobas conjecture something
like that just add as an axium well
eventually it becomes very incoherent
when you've just sort of added
everything as an axiom you you no longer
have this sort of coherent view of the
world and I think the same is true with
the sort of computational reducibility
if you have enough different pockets of
reducibility the world gets very
complicated again because you're like
picking between it's like all these
devices that that you know manage to do
a little bit of sort of jumping through
computational
reducibility you then you it's like pick
which device you want to use my guess is
that in our universe we never get to
fully transcend computational
irreducibility pick another Universe you
can but you'll never be able to
communicate between that universe and
ours so I think we're kind of stuck I
think it's kind of an inevitable feature
of the the fundamental structure of the
idea of computation the idea of
following rules that we as entities
embedded in the universe which is also
following rules will experience
computational irreducibility and I think
that's true at whatever level of sort of
the computational hierarchy we're at
because the universe is just like us and
we are part of the universe it's
inevitable by sort of a diagonal kind of
arguments in in sort of mathematical
logic kinds of ideas it's sort of
inevitable that there will be
computational irreducibility for
us let's see prab comments why does
pessimism towards future technology
exist experiences that most people's
default opinion on future Tech is let's
not do
this well I think that's a mixed bag
because there are things
where the there are things there have
been cases where sort of being naive
about what the consequences of something
are is not very good I mean you might
say gosh we can do artificial selection
of humans you know we can breed humans
uh to do Eugenics for example oh whoops
that leads to this or that or the other
very bad
consequence it's I think what what often
happens is and what makes people
suspicious about sort of let's do future
technology and it will be great is
people say it will just be great nothing
could possibly go wrong we know exactly
what will happen let's put this thing in
here let's start doing this and you know
what could possibly go wrong type thing
computational irreducibility is the
story of there is always something that
could go wrong and as soon as you go
into it with kind of this this attitude
of it's science we know nothing can go
wrong then you get yourself in trouble I
think a humbler attitude where it's like
look we can do this there will be things
that will happen that we will not
foresee and then we have to deal with
those and then we have to deal with
those but just the look you know
everybody you should do this this and
this because it's what science says
that's a mistake and I think when that
gets said that's when people I think
rightfully get suspicious about is this
a good idea you know should we do you
know should we make superv viruses that
will you know be able to wipe out the
species so to speak well you know maybe
it may be harder to do that than one
thinks my guess is it is harder to do
that than one thinks but it's still like
that seems like an obviously bad idea
but it's also something where somehow
you know you say well we'll do this and
this and this and we can scientifically
show the virus will never get out or
whatever else it is uh you know it
it's it's kind of you have to expect the
unexpected so to speak the idea that
science will just say yep we got it all
under control it's just going to work
this way nothing unexpected will happen
that's wrong and that's something that
has been sort of a a mistake of science
for the last few hundred years that's a
consequence of the fact that bunch of
science that we bit off starting in the
1600s does have that feature that the
stuff we bit off we are able to say yep
it works this way nothing could possibly
go wrong but that's not the whole story
that's the story of the particular
pieces of mechanics or whatever else
that we chose to study it's not the full
story of everything that can happen that
full story involves computational
irreducibility and involves things that
can go wrong so to
speak now in terms of of you know the
question of sort of people's General
attitude towards the future I think one
has to realize that we all have a
certain set of things that we've leared
that we're comfortable with and so on
and some of us I mean I know it's a it's
a thing that even has genetic correlates
in in in mice and so on some of us are
more like oh I want to do something new
than others it's kind of that that's a
thing which probably we're all set at a
certain level of we want to do N Things
versus we don't but we all have a
certain degree of look look I'm I'm
familiar with this I like this I don't
want to you know that that's where I'm
comfortable so to speak so when the new
comes in it's a question of sort of how
does one adapt to the new and for some
people it's very disorienting that's
true when it comes to ideas and
paradigms and so on it's true when it
comes to societal the way Society is set
up it's um uh you know there there are
different cases of that but I think that
that's that there's a certain uh you
know there's a certain I would say
perhaps rational sort of fear of the new
because well gosh then you have to put a
lot of effort into learning the new and
so on and that so in a sense when we
bring in new technology part of the
point is can you make that new
technology comfortable to people can you
for example one of the things that is
often an issue with using interfaces is
can you make that user interface remind
people enough of something that they
already knew that they can deal with it
or or in the design of computational
language when we build that we are using
English words for names of functions and
so on because that is something people
already know we're building on something
people already know it's sort of an
interesting thing I mean the the
different Trends in user interface
design from the kind of skew morphic
design where it's kind of yes it should
look like a you know a leather padded
desk top or something um and does it
really have to how how how Faithfully
does it have to represent what people
are familiar with and what became clear
was it can be pretty cartoonish and
people are still fine with that it seems
unnecessary to have some of this detail
it's only sort of the essentials that
that you need to
capture so
uh you know I
think yeah I mean this this question of
of whether one
should you know what one thing about the
future and I suppose it's kind of like
you imagine the case where you know
you're cryonically Frozen for 200 years
you wake up again The Future Has
Arrived what is it like and what you
realize by thinking about the historical
span of this is the future may be very
unfamiliar and even
very perhaps even uninteresting perhaps
even
disorienting because the things that are
incredibly important to us today might
not be things that are incredibly
important in the future just as it
wasn't the same set of things that were
important in the past and I think that
that's another feature of kind of the
the arrival of the future it's kind of
like look I just don't get why all these
kids worry about how many likes they get
on Instagram or something I don't get
why all these people want to do you know
there's the the every generation is
always saying about the next one I don't
get why these people are you know
communicating an emoji or something like
this like the ancient Egyptians perhaps
but but um you know whatever else it is
but why you know why this this thing has
changed in this way I don't get it and
that's you know that that's uh and so as
you as you sort of Imagine The Future
there's this question of are you going
to care about the future or is the
future just going to be about things
that are that are profoundly different
from what you care about I mean there
are plenty of things that happen in
today's world which from 200 years ago
people would like you say this is what
what we're doing this is what we're um
and people would just like shrug their
shoulders why do you want to do that you
know that just seems like a silly thing
to
do let's see a few more questions let me
go backwards here in my
list
uh M rudo asks can we calculate how wind
energy will influence the weather in the
future if we become independent of
fossil
fuels you know I've wondered about that
it's kind of like Downstream from a wind
farm how does it change the wind the
fact is the rotation of the earth which
is what eventually drives the wind and
so on there's a lot of energy in the
rotation of the earth and it's going to
take a lot to slow the Earth down I
don't think we could use uh you know the
the the energy associated with the
rotational energy of the earth is just
vast compared to a lot of other thing
kinds of things not as vast as the
energy associated with Fusion in the Sun
it's an interesting question how it
Compares with the energy associated with
the heat inside the earth kind of the
the ultimate deep ultimately deep
geothermal energy I don't know the
answer to that I probably if I thought
for a little bit i' probably calculate
that let me see can I do that
calculation
easily no if I if I were typing into wol
MAF I think I I think I know how to get
to that calculation in a couple of
minutes but I I I can't immediately tell
you my my intuition would be the heat of
the earth is more significant source of
energy than the rotation of the earth
which can be captured by wind and so on
but in any case the the um uh I so I
would not expect that that we'll slow
the Earth down that way um or that uh uh
or that all wind will be gone so to
speak um I think it's uh um you know in
in the
end the energy use that we humans have I
mean there's certain kinds of reasons
that we use energy and it's question of
you know how could we scale up let's say
energy was super cheap was a million
times cheaper than it is today and was
completely uh kind of renewable and and
all those kinds of good things and um
what would we do with it what would we
do with vastly more energy and and how
would it change sort of Technology
Society
Etc I mean I'm I'm not sure I think we
would be able to uh oh for example you
know things flying around would be a lot
easier things um you know it would be
much more routine to be you know have
the Drone that you know just put this
thing on you know drones if if if energy
was sufficiently cheap everything might
as well fly and there's a lot more room
in in three-dimensional space than there
is on the surface of the Earth forget
roads just have everything fly um and I
think that's one example in terms of uh
there's a question of of if you can move
stuff around much more easily than you
can right now how would that change
things would it be the case that I
suppose that there are things one could
imagine where right
now you kind of have to yeah I mean I
suppose one can imagine a bizarre kind
of this is a cloud computing analog of
owning things back in you know when in
these Trends seem to sort of go
cyclically in computers you know do you
want the personal computer on your desk
or do you want just the computer power
in the cloud somewhere connected via the
Internet well that's taking the bits and
having them the bits flow through the
internet to the cloud computer to the
server somewhere and then come back to
you or do you want the bits locally on
your computer well if you could move
stuff around more easily maybe you do
the analog of cloud computing for for
stuff that is I don't need to own
anything at every time I need a thing I
just you know press a button and a drone
delivers the thing I need and then no
clutter drone takes it away stores it in
the cloud somewhere and and probably If
energy is is cost nothing it might
actually be in the cloud there might be
some you know flying platform that's the
giant Warehouse in the sky type thing
that um uh you know that has all these
things stored and whenever you need
something it's just like okay let me get
that thing oh I'm done with that let me
just send it away again it's kind of
like the library of stuff so to speak
and that's the kind of thing one could
imagine if if energy was cheap enough
I'm I'm kind of wondering what other
things I mean I suppose that when it
comes to Computing right now there's a
certain energy cost in Computing that
doesn't need to be there we certainly
know in principle how to do Computing in
a completely reversible way that doesn't
require the the dissipation of energy
the dissipation of heat um it hasn't
been not that many experiments have been
done in doing that in practice but my
guess is that that will not be the
dominant source of you know the fact
that servers run so hot and you go to a
a Data Center and it's like belching out
heat and so on I don't think that's a
permanent kind of issue I think that's
an issue of today's technology and the
fact that you know transistors are a
certain size and etc etc etc and the
capacitance is are this or that I don't
think that's a necessary feature of
those kinds of
things let's see there a question for
here from
about what's there to say about the
future of Food Science will someone be
able to recreate Wily Wonka's
Creations you know taste is a sense that
we don't understand that well you know
we have taste buds in our tongues it's
like food gets smooshed in there the
actual texture of the Food Matters the
um uh the details of the shapes of the
molecules matter I just learned actually
I didn't even know this that the the
crunchy creamy you know different kinds
of food textur in your mouth they are
literally correlated with the shapes of
the proteins in foods and uh so that
means you know if you're eating fibbr
blast cells muscle cells in in a piece
of meat that there's a there's a
microscopic texture associated with the
fact that you have those actin you know
filaments that are that are in there
versus that you're having some quite
different kind of protein from something
else so in a sense taste is all about
sort of is is a lot about the the both
the the chemical interaction between the
molecule and the shapes of molecules and
and how they bind into the taste
receptors and the physicality of the
structure of the food at a level beyond
the individual molecules of how the
pieces put together how do they smoosh
onto your tongue or whatever else and I
think you know the whole area of
Molecular Gastronomy of of kind of
trying to understand at the level from
the level of molecules level of clusters
of molecules to level of whole things of
food so to speak how that has an effect
on our uh you know how we sense that
from a taste point of view that's
something that's still I think somewhat
in its infancy I mean we are much more
able to you know for sound we can kind
of we can create pretty much whatever
sound we want it's still not easy you
know if you say make me a new kind of
musical instrument well that's still in
the domain of at the outer limit of what
llms start to be able to do um in in
visual perception you know make me a
picture of this or that we we're
starting to be able to do that in a
reasonable way make me a thing that
tastes like this well actually I think
the biggest challenge there will be the
how you describe what you want it to
taste like because we don't have good
words for that really we have pretty
coarse linguistic correlates of of taste
and but if you say if you say make me
use generative AI to make me molecules
will have this characteristic and that
character itic not sure you necessarily
need that much Ai and loop but you know
we can imagine doing that obviously
there are efforts to do that with
artificial meat and things like this
which is so far A little bit you know
the the my own experiences of of eating
those things I I wasn't that impressed
yet um and I think the uh uh but but
that's you know I think think the idea
that you can kind of create a taste
create a food with with certain
characteristics I I think that is a a
becoming attraction so to speak I mean
it partly is affected by how do you make
a molecule of a kind you want with
proteins it's fairly easy it's the trick
that biology came up with of you just
have the DNA sequence and you transcribe
the DNA sequence and you got this
protein and so long as you can get a
protein that folds up to the right shape
you want you're in good shape but
literally um but you know if you want to
make other kinds of molecules we don't
have good ways to do that we don't have
a good sort of standard method for
making other molecules we have to do
chemical synthesis which involves you
know taking all of these sort of named
reactions and saying how do I do this
reaction then that reaction then that
reaction to make this molecule have this
little end on it here and oh we don't
want that end to fall off when we have
this reaction happen we have to have to
plan these reactions very carefully it's
kind of like an a theorum proving thing
where you would sort of apply this axium
apply that axium apply this reaction to
this molecule that reaction and so on
see whether you get out this this final
shape of molecule that you want that's
still a thing that is not well
characterized it's something that's
that's there's a over a long period of
time there's sort of computational
efforts to be able to do that but you
know and even in that case if you say
well what's it going to taste like if I
make a molecule that's this shape we
don't know that yet we don't have a good
way to predict that and that's that's
something that I would expect will will
come over the over the next uh uh
limited is number of years
let's
see
uh let's
um uh yeah got a few comments about wind
turbine say that people are making most
of energy in wind is not on the ground
it's over oceans and up in the sky yeah
I mean that's sort of undoubtedly the
case because at you know when fluid like
air flows over a solid surface right at
the solid surface that fluid is is is
not slipping relative to the solid
surface so it's at rest relative to the
solid surface you go up 30,000 fet in
the air you might have 100 mph winds you
don't get 100 mph wind as easily at
least as something that can slip across
the surface so yes inevitably there's
there's more wind up higher and how you
capture that in gosh I don't know how
you capture that in in um uh kind of
Because by the time you're sort
of a thing that's floating in the air
it's like you're you're co-moving with
the air it's not like it's when you're a
wind turbine that's you know rooted to
the ground and you've got this great you
know these big BL blades and and the the
air is pushing past you and you're
rooted to the ground you're using that
fact that you're rooted to the ground so
I don't know how you capture the things
higher up unless you know and this is
again what will happen in the future you
know will there be super materials that
allow you to build a wind turbine that's
five miles high for example certainly
not possible today the materials we have
today are simply not strong enough to do
that I mean people have certainly hoped
that um uh carbon nanot tubes things
like that might be might be knitted
together to um uh might be spun together
so to speak to make materials that are
that strong but that hasn't been been
been reduced to practice yet uh and and
that you know there's nothing that says
that there is no there's no theoretical
if if you look at the the uh forces that
bind atoms together those forces are
strong enough that you could build sort
of super materials that are that are
capable of making you know the the wind
turbine five miles high but how to
actually realize that in practice with
an actual material that's not known how
to do but certainly not I don't think
there's a theoretical reason why that's
impossible I mean as as you get longer
and longer and longer eventually it
becomes impossible if you say let's take
this thing it's on the surface of the
Earth it's a rigid object and it's
rotating with the Earth if you go out
far enough the tips of that rigid object
will be rotating faster than the speed
of light and you kind of know that no
material can hang hold together under
those circumstances necessarily as you
as you have the Giant propeller and it's
super super long and the tips of the
propeller blades are going faster than
the speed of light the the reason that
doesn't work the reason you don't get to
go FAS than the speed of light there is
that there are internal stresses that
necessarily build up in the object that
prevent you from Ever Getting that thing
constructed in that way just as a even
as a result of change of mass with
velocity and things you'll get good
effects like
that so
um let's see Joe asks K one describe a
computation engine analogous to a
thermodynamic engine where useful work
is a consequence of information
processing well what you have to realize
is useful work is sort of systematic
motion a great big sort of Wheel of a
steam engine moves or something or a
great big piston in a steam engine moves
lots of molecules all moving together in
an organized way as opposed to there's
this just this hot gas where all the
molecules are moving around randomly and
the key fact in thermodynamics the
second law of Thermodynamics says
something which starts a systematic
motion tends to degrade into randomized
heat and the challenge then is how do
you take that randomized heat and turn
it into something that you think of as
being organized motion now if we were
much smaller than we are and we were at
the size of molecules we might say oh
that that thing you call heat and you
call random that's where all the action
all the interesting stuff is happening
but this question about how do you take
sort of Randomness and turn it into
something systematic that's kind of the
essence of of turning heat into
mechanical work and I suppose it's an
interesting question actually maybe an
interesting way to think about it is how
do you turn Randomness into mechanical
work actually now that I think about it
there are many many algorithms that make
make use of Randomness and extract from
it mechanical you know useful work so
it's a little bit like if you have a
ratchet that is you know there's it's
randomly being kicked one way or another
and every so often it it it catches on
the
ratchet the the uh in the end such a
setup will in the end the ratchet will
produce enough heat that the thing will
eventually sort of run down but for a
while at least you get to sort of
progressively ratch It Forward just by
randomly driving it with heat
and when thinks about all sorts of
algorithms that exist including ones in
machine learning where there's lots of
Randomness that's made use of and it's
sort of you're jiggling around randomly
and every so often you hit something
that you really want and you grab onto
it a little bit like the ratchet and
that uh that's the thing that's useful
so in a sense I suppose that's the
analogy to the creation of useful work
from from heat is these randomized
algorithms where you're saying let's not
systematically go and try and find find
this thing let's just randomly try all
these different possibilities and see
whether we can catch on to one that's
useful I mean I think I haven't thought
that's true and that actually not
occurred to me that that was an analogy
there but I think that's a useful
analogy for sort of the creation of of
um of mechanical work from heat it's the
creation of systematic knowledge
systematic information from sort of
random sampling now you know could one
invent good question could one invent uh
ious analoges of you know Caro's
efficiency for a heat engine and things
and Notions of temperature and so on for
that case I think it's quite possible it
would be interesting to do I hadn't
thought of it before so thanks for um
uh thanks for
that um Lynn is asking can AI solve The
Taste problem as it did the protein
folding problem yeah I think the the AI
has totally know nailed protein folding
is a little bit oversold if you really
have a random sequence of amino acids
like you do in the immune
system we still don't know what that's
going to fold up into it's when it's
something which can readily be
extrapolated from the proteins we've DET
analyzed in detail with PR
electromicroscopy or or um
crystallography or something that we
that we can do it so it's not really
quite the case that sort of the random
protein thrown in oh yeah we know how it
folds yet so the question of could we
solve tastes in the same way that one
solved protein folding I would think the
answer is yes in fact I think it might
even be easier I think the problem is
what are you going for you know if you
say well so a question would be you know
take chocolate one of my favorite foods
and ask the question I don't actually
know and I should all the details of
which molecules lead chocolate to taste
like chocolate and so on I mean I I
think it's the you know the cocoa
proteins and so on but um don't know in
in in in total detail how that works but
say let's say I want to make artificial
chocolate and uh I mean in a sense it's
not that exciting to say I'll make an
artificial protein it's going to be
taste like the Protein that's in
chocolate the only case where that would
be interesting yeah here's here's a case
that's interesting if you're allergic to
food X I'm not allergic for very much I
discovered at some point that I'm
allergic to kiwi fruit but um that's
about the only thing I know but let's
imagine that I really like the taste of
kiwi fruit but I know I'm allergic the
specific shaped proteins in kiwi fruit
then I could imagine something where I
could go to my Ai and say make me
something that's going to taste like
kiwi fruit as far as my taste receptors
are concerned but which will not lock on
to my immune system to give me an
allergic reaction I I think that's an
interesting thing to think about is you
know there presumably presumably I don't
know this for sure but presumably
certainly the mechanisms are very
different for the immune response the
Adaptive immune response and The Taste
response even though they are molecular
recognition mechanisms and one certainly
could imagine that one could kind of
squiggle through you know yes it's going
to be the right taste response but it
isn't going to excite the all allergic
response those kinds of things so that's
a that's a place where one can imagine
doing
that
uh comment about specifically about
chocolate at a shop in Cambridge
Massachusetts well I don't know I'll be
back in Massachusetts uh uh next week so
um the I I don't know any uh anything
that remarkable there let me see um okay
maybe one more thing
here
uh
okay Dash comments if we could run our
Evolution over and over again maybe we
would see ourselves in some different
shapes floating in space with different
forms of communication exchanging
thoughts telepathically Etc what do I
think about that yeah I
mean this is the question of why is life
the way life is and is is there a thing
that is kind of like life but off on a
different branch you know doesn't use
carbon uses germanium instead doesn't
have uh eyes instead everything is based
on you know sensing gravitational waves
they were much bigger to be able to do
that but but um uh you know
or I think it's a question of what what
is the category of thing that you're
trying to ask does it happen because in
the universe lots of stuff has happened
the things that we choose to call life
are mostly things well so far it's
purely things that are historically
related to life on Earth things which
have the particular details of life on
Earth cell membranes you know uh RNA
lots of very very detailed things about
the particular history of life on Earth
the general category of thing that we
would characterize as life we don't
really know what that is my my guess is
and and I've sort of increasingly
beginning to understand this I suppose
it's this kind of weird phase of matter
that is living matter that has this sort
of bulk orchestration of activity where
the molecules aren't doing just
completely quotes random things like
they are in a gas where where we as
observers like us just say oh it's
random but they're doing things where
there's a lot of detail in what they're
doing which is sort of understandable to
observers like us if we were able to go
in with sufficiently good senses and so
on but yet it's kind of um uh it's kind
of it's not something where we can just
summarize everything and say this is how
it all works it's something where there
is sort of detailed uh detailed action
but it's all orchestrated but it's a lot
of detail it's kind of like if you were
to open up you know your average
computer your average microprocessor
you'd see electrons going around all
kinds of complicated patterns and you
wouldn't you would say they're going
around in complicated patterns but there
is some some uh uh sort of meaning to
what's going on there is some
organization to what's going on there's
some organization that we can recognize
in what's going on and I think it
becomes a bit of a circular thing
because we are life as life as we are as
we are and if we say well is that other
thing over there life we're going to
project our own form of organization
onto answering the question of is that
life is it kind of life like we think
about life or is it life uh in a in a
you know in a in a way that's how far
away you know how far away in the space
of possible things that we would call
life can you go and still have us
identify those things as as life so to
speak speak so I think it's it's a um uh
what you know is there bulk
orchestration that could happen in a way
that's different from the way it happens
for us I'm sure the answer is yes um and
how far away would it be how
recognizable to us would it be I'm not
sure and would there be things where we
could summarize What's Happening by
saying oh it's using telepathy or
something I'm not sure um I think this
is a is one of a whole category of
questions about sort of how other minds
work that um I think is really
interesting and uh I've tried to poke
out a lot but I don't really know um how
to uh um how to make that work surge
comments um about my previous thing
about about kiwi fruit um would it be
easier to genetically modify the Kiwi
itself yeah it might be although
although taste is known to be very
sensitive and dependent on genetics so
for example if you take different varie
I of apples for instance you know a
golden delicious apple my favorite is
they are all genetically identical they
are all clones and if you took something
which was genetically even slightly
different it would taste significantly
different it it really seems to depend
taste seems very sensitive and dependent
on the very particular you know amino
acid sequence in those particular
proteins so the modified you know it's a
it's a tricky thing you'd have to you
have to find out well what's the we
don't really understand food allergies
very well to begin with it's kind of
like well what part of what protein is
the thing that is and maybe you can find
that out by just looking at
immunoglobulins that that exist in in
high abundances in the immune system
when you have that allergic reaction I'm
not sure and say well what does that
match on the original uh protein of this
particular fruit and then let's zap that
part but count on the fact that it's
mostly other parts that are leading to
the characteristic taste it has yeah
reasonable reasonable
thought all right um I think I need to
wrap up and go back to my day job but I
look forward to chatting with you all
another
time see you see you on another stream
bye for
now